well I'm joined now by the British
Olympic marathon runner Mara Yamauchi
and by rapper and podcast host Zoo big
great to see you here zubi who once took
part in a weightlifting competition four
years ago as a woman to kind of prove a
point and guess what
he won
and by talk TV contributor Paula Ron
Adrian who will still be attempting to
defend the indefensible on this issue
well Clinique Frank uh just to be clear
or Glenn Frank whichever uh Glenn or
glenick is identifying as this week was
invited to appear but pulled out this
morning and like I say uh Glennie or
Glenn again we don't know who's Lenny's
going back to being Glennon future races
and has always run as Glenn before
um did did say it was wrong but you are
asked when you enter the London Marathon
which category do you want to run it
male or female
or non-binary
it's ridiculous the whole thing is
ridiculous as I keep saying but there
are still people who think this is
perfectly fair and equal and we should
all just stop making such a fuss about
it so let's have a little chat about
this uh well simply let me start with
you because you come all the way in here
great to see you in London I love the
fact that you tested almost four years
ago and you did it to raise the problem
as an issue and of course you demolished
all the females that you're up against
because physically as a biological male
You're simply more powerful but you
expose the futility if you like an
unfairness and inequality of
self-identity if it becomes Limitless
like this yeah absolutely
um I've been talking for more than five
years at this point but especially the
past four publicly about the absurdity
of the issue and that's why back in
February 2019 I had that tweet I put out
there with a video of me breaking the
British women's deadlift record while
claiming I identified as you literally
broke the women's record yeah so to be
clear it wasn't in a sanctioned
competition but it was from one of my
training sessions just showing how
easily I could lift a weight that's well
we're looking at it this is you as a
woman yeah it wasn't exactly Difficult
about 17 Paula Ron Adrians and I know
you're like a bit of weightlifting Paul
I said why don't you try and lift a bit
of that later in your gym we'll see how
you get on he's a spoiler alert you
won't be able to
um not because you're not a very strong
lady and not because you're not a very
committed athlete in your own right
because if the biological differences no
do you get it myself it's the penny
dropping so I get it but what I wonder
is whether you get it peers what am I
missing what I wonder is why it is
you're struggling with the fact that
some people are different I don't and
and the people who have decided that
they are different and who want to live
a different life some of them have the
capacity to do that medically and
legally and they should be permitted
always have done always supported trans
people's rights to fairness inequality
okay so right right to the point it
clearly erodes women's rights that's my
only concern about it so where the
absurdity comes I worry is where we've
got this example of the marathon runner
and this was a fun run it's the marathon
it's not a fun run right it's awesome
it's a great no no tens of thousands of
people raise a ton of money and it's a
serious competitive rate it's a great
example of people getting the
opportunity to push themselves not only
personally but also in terms of their
charitable Charities and this is a
person who did that and they are nice
so fearful they've had to apologize
they've had to offer to hand back their
medal well they want their vehicles
because because Glenn entered as Glenn
eek and Glennie finished a lot further
in the race in the women's field than
Glenn would have done in the men's field
and how relevant is that to you peers
actually to everyone I know to everybody
I know that racism a London marathon
every position counts they all want to
improve their time it wasn't a gold
medal actually the ones this was the
Front Runners in the London it was about
taking part so you think it's
meaningless London Marathon no
absolutely it's actually taken I've I've
it's actually one of them and I see and
people running past me I see people
running past me of all different sizes
shapes uh running for all different
types of causes and that's what it's all
about it's inclusivity but let me bring
in an actual Olympians rather than
somebody who sounds like she thinks
you're to be one uh Mara you've been
listening very patiently to all this
you've been a proper athlete here just
try and explain to me well to Paula
really why this is so unfair
so males and females have there's a
massive difference in our physical
abilities in upper body strength like in
zooby's uh bench press and deadlift uh
Women's World Records you know there's a
massive massive difference in running
it's about 10 therefore we must have
sex-based categories male and female
otherwise females would be entirely
absent from Sport and to answer Paula's
point about it being a fun run yes a lot
of people in enjoy it and do great
things like raising money but Glenn
could have done that in the men's
category and not caused unfairness for
the 20 000 odd females who ran in the in
the mass race I have to also clarify
that Glenn ran as Glenn in the Tokyo
Marathon last month but also in the
women's category as he did in London and
you know you can say well the mass race
is just a bit of fun the mass race at
the London Marathon but an event like
that is either a sports competition or
it isn't if you're gonna say it's just a
fun run the then why do they have a
measured course why do they have timing
equipment and a referee to enforce the
rules you know even if people enjoy
themselves and and earn and raise money
for charity it still is a comp a
competition rules matter and people have
to respect the rules and Glenn on on GB
news gave an interview last night it was
clear he had no idea what the rules are
he was talking about uh surgery and
passports but the rules British
Athletics rules which apply to the
London Marathon required testosterone
suppression to under five nanomoles for
12 months to become eligible and then
continue suppression to remain eligible
he was talking about hormone therapy in
the future tense so it's clear he's done
no testosterone suppression at all he
wasn't eligible for the female category
and therefore my view is he should be
disqualified because he he hasn't he's
just not he's not eligible well no
question there's no question of that I
mean it was interesting to me two things
about about you in particular one your
courage and speaking out about this
because you were of course immediately
bombarded with insults and abuse and
threats called a transphobe a Turf their
favorite phrase for stating what a
simple biological facts but also you are
you by your own emission you're slightly
left-leaning you're not on the right
you're not trying to score some
political Point against the left and
like a lot of people I mean I you know
I've always probably politically been
slightly left to Center maybe Center I'm
really a journalist I don't really care
about an ideology either way to be
honest with you but
um I'm certainly not on the right but
like a lot of people like you like me
like Bill Maher interviewed last week in
America we find ourselves completely
bemused that people so-called liberals
on this Ultra woke side now the the of
the spectrum I've lost their minds
yeah I mean I've been a center-left
voter all my life but for me this isn't
about left or right for me this is about
the rights to safety dignity privacy and
in sport Fair competition and safety for
51 of the population and people say oh
Clinique only finished 6100 and
something you know get a life but nearly
000 women suffered a worse finished
position what I would say to people who
say that is okay how many women do you
think it's okay to suffer to indulge the
feelings of one male competing in the
female give us a number yeah I totally
agree and what about I mean I said Paula
what about Laurel Hubbard the New
Zealand weightlifter who qualified uh
for the first Olympics a couple of years
ago having said
records in the women's field but she
took the place of a woman weightlifter
the average age for the weightlifters in
that competition was about half Laurel
Harbor's age she'd been very
unsuccessful as a male weightlifted by
comparison but she deprived a biological
female of an Olympic place in that team
that to me is completely wrong now
someone said to be on TV in America last
week a female congresswoman well what
would you do about it then I went well
fine I want trans athletes to compete
fairly and to be able to compete so they
either compete against their biological
sex which seems to me physically fair or
they have a completely new category of
transport why not so there's there's two
things here just getting back to the
marathon if if Clinique wasn't eligible
then there's no discussion here because
absolutely if if she wasn't eligible
then she wasn't eligible
what I'm talking about in terms of the
marathon is when I ran the marathon I
was running with men and women uh young
people old people all running together
and what I'm saying is is this fear that
the headlines around this is bringing up
it's bringing up a fear it's making very
vulnerable people and we know that
they're very vulnerable because we're
told by the stats that they are the most
likely group of people to commit suicide
so this is not just about a fun run this
is not just about women who require
vulnerable spaces this is not what we're
talking okay I would say to that the the
of course I'm very aware of the issues
that trans people have had and continue
to have but I think people like Leah
Thomas people like glenick here they
cause massive bigger problems for the
trans Community they make the whole
thing look like a mockery they make a
mockery of being trans yeah and when you
put your hand up as a six foot four inch
biological manner say I am now competing
against women in swimming pool
no trans person who doesn't want that
attention is doing anything other than
saying this is making my life hell why
are you doing this yeah you're
absolutely right in that the so-called
activists are harming the group that
they're claiming to advocate for as well
as harming 51 of the of the whole human
population because let's be real all of
this stuff all the negative Downstream
impacts are on girls on women they are
not on boys and men at all I'd say this
whole thing is incredibly misogynistic
and I don't like to throw that word
around too much today conversation up a
level as well I have a question and the
whole thing is why are we trying to
force people and why are so many people
entertaining the denial of reality
itself yeah women's rights are
incredibly important fairness in sports
is important safety and security and
privacy all of these things are very
important the fundamental problem at the
root of this is everyone dancing around
pretending that a man can truly be a
woman and a woman can truly be a man
this is not me being transphobic or
hateful or being a bigot anything like
that it's simply that reality exists
biology is real and is that reality
legal one because
reality
means your gender cannot change your
biological sex it's physically
impossible I'm I'm saying to you it is
impossible
can you change your biology we can talk
about biology and we can talk about the
legality we're talking about biology
though we're talking this thing is about
sport this is about males and females
well the problem when we talk about
biology is either of us are scientists
you and I both know that it's a lot more
complicated what's that what's the
complication it's not as simple as for
me it's very interesting you it may be
very simple but we are I think we're
being we're indulging and ignorant I
cannot suggest can you become can you
become can you become male I don't want
to be I can't become meal is there
anything that could be done that could
turn you into a male in the way that I'm
a male and pierces meal is that is that
possible now do you see how you've
qualified your question so you first
and I would suggest probably yes in
terms of medically but then then you
said then you said you know then you
said like you and peers and that's where
we start to get comfortable I hope he
would have taken you a little further
down your journey
you can become male you can't because I
can have it I can have a gen I can have
gender recognition all right I can
legally become a male we've got to leave
it there but you can't actually become a
biological male
female because I'm quite tempted right
now to start entering the cricket
competition right and smashing female
biological Bowlers all over the place of
feeling good about myself only I
wouldn't I'd feel ashamed I think I
think it's embarrassing your uh pumping
above your weight there
it is as I say wait till Usain Bolt goes
I'm identifying as a woman it runs 100
meter final at the Olympics and you'll
all go well done you see me hold on you
see me it's a joke uh anyway Paula
lovely to see you thank you Mara thank
you very much for joining us it's gonna
be great to have you here in London
really appreciate you coming into uh and
go follow this guy on Twitter who just
passed a million followers on Twitter so
only seven and a half million to catch
me
which I know he's Keen to do